- Comment comment faire pour
une personne qui refuse comme
ça votre pratique vous en avez
vu?
- Les dépressions aussi séortent
plus dplus dplus dplus de chez t
complètement inactifs,
complètement coupés due une
condition assez courante la
dépression majeure. Ce que j'ai
trouvé exceptionnel inhabi
dans le reportage Monsieur
Thériault céderait que ça a prie
rencontrer un soignant, un
psychiatre. Ça semble as ce qu'n
comprend. Ça, habituellement,
les gens dépress conditions donc
que les proches souvent les
encouragent const être t être te
ce Sylvain avant d'aller vers
les soins, c'est assezionnel. Js
vu ça dans sa pratique.ent une t
paralysée à ce. Là, le rendre
complètement recluses?d'une
part dans le secteur de la
dépression il y e
complète d'intérêt, de plaisir,
de motivation et
Les moindres târ prendre
une marche est allée faire le
tri peître coître coître coîtree
montagne. Même sortir de leur
lit ouivan. L'autre
élément ce qui a une perte très
forte des ces personnels qui
peut a
soi. Les gens ne veulent pas
exposer ça aux autres. Ils sont
honteume ils se sentent
souvent coupables. Ils ne sont
ers de. Ce documentaire il je nà
je ne suis plus capable de faire
a conjointe ni ma fille.
On sentait cette dévalorisation
la.z-y.symptsymptsymptsymptsympi
accompagnent la dépression,c'ess
peuvent avoir de l'anxiété, de
l'anxiété sociale est trèsintime
diagnostic en onde et on n'est
pas là-dedans. Mais le fait pour
n'importe qui qu'elle connaît
une carrière éblouissante. Il a
une superbe carrière. Est-ce que
ça rend les gens qui ont eu de
grands succès professionnels
peut-être plus fragile
ce sont mes attentes tellement
autres, le regard des autres
que ça compte ça ou pas?
- La personnalit
personne, il s'agit d'abord on
est pa
personnalisé, ses traits
individuels. C'est sûr que lesrs
perforque ce
soit ndans le spdans le spdans ,
zones problématiques, c'est ce
r l'impressionber de hauber de s
pertes qui lui a ce moment-là
mportantes. Le passé de
province a une personne qui
ans. C'est un énorme sud de
fonctionnement ou de statut. En
termes... parfois les axes
t beaucoup de pressionveulenveus
autres ça peut être une pressioe
gens qui font tout pour effet de
l'aider. Si on est un proche qui
a une grande dépression, o
que le poisson difficile puis on
aboutirait, pousser ou
convaincre ou flatter, des fois
ça ne marche pas?
quand arrive pas le convai
donner envie de me faire
confiance et de
difficile pour les proches.
- C'est très difficile parce que
en fait c'est moi qu'on crée une
maladie mentale
physique. Quand quelqu'un de
quelquconcret.concret.concret.c.
Quand
abstrait c'est plus difficile de
barrière qu'est-ce qui t'empêche
de sors
effectivement le fait que
ont ont ont ont ont ont ont ons
proches vont se mettre de
pression de dire je dois être ma
faute n'arrive pas le
'arrive pas lui
dire ce qu'il faudrait pour le
faire sourire pour le rendreue t
beaucoup plus complexe que ça. t
justement les informer de leur
limite aussi. Ils ne peuvent pas
prendre la souffrance de la
personne sur leurs épaules et la
- C'est très lourde tout ça.doce
de le regarder jusqu'au boutpoue
cherche de l'aide. Tout le
de santé mentale mais la
révélait que des problèconsommat
exclure les problèmes mentale qe
consommation?
trouble mentale sous-jacente
soient un trouble anxieux
dépression justement. Il peut y
avoir aussi une dépendance aux
substances indép
les deux sont possibles. De
toute façon, le trouble d'abus
de substances et
soi tu
sur le plan médical. Moi, je
trouve ça par contre assez
figure que
les hommes consultent encore
ntale
que les femmes et c'est une des
lesquels ils se suicident plus.
Alors de commencer avoir des
connues se tourner vers les
services en disant, ça peute. Çt
arrivé. Je pense que l'impactc'e
passe une vedette de cette qui r
héros du hockey qui a connu ces
moments et ses blessures, on le
publiquement, de faire cet aveu
il y a finalement le côté
l'exemple qu'on donne là
- Absolument. Il acquit une
représentation de la mascudes tt
de la masculine - tonnelle elle
est encore beauc
valeurs masculines optionnelles
ou l'autonomie, c'est-à-dire
l'idée qu'un hom
problème seul ne peut pas avoir
besoin
mascul
au fait d'aller chercher de
- Il brise un tabou d'une
n
plaisir de vous recevoir en
entrevue, merci pour vos
en
onde centre d'écoute ets gens en
auraient besoin. Si vous avez un
proche et que vous pensez